you have been longtime friends with and
had amazing conversations with people of
other
faiths
Christian
Jewish how has uh the events of October
7th and the days after affected this in
the United States your ability to have
Interfaith
conversations connections relationships
friendships complicated
very
complicated um and it's not just Muslims
and Jews it's also Christian zionists
Christian Zionism is at the root of the
problem in my opinion especially when we
talk about what drives uh America's
unshakable unconditional commitment to
to Israel
um it's devastating I think to
Palestinian Christians in
particular when Israel can bomb some of
the oldest churches of Christianity in
Gaza and kill Palestinian Christians and
Palestinian Christians are barred from
going to the holy supplier or to their
places of worship in Bethlehem or
Jerusalem and Christians here in the
United States turn their back on them I
think that it is particularly outrageous
so it's complicated um look I I I expect
more from people in the face of a
genocide we don't have to agree on all
the
particulars but we can agree that what
is happening is morally outrageous and
so I think that
um I've had a few people that have
reached out and said I want to say
something but I
can't and I've had to respond with
that's not good enough so I think that
we have a we have a
problem and instead of focusing on that
problem I'd like to focus on the more
morally consistent voices across Fates
that have risen to the moment rather
than those that have
failed so you wish more rabbis would be
able to have a conversation like we're
having
today and
also not allow it to be
seen as them turning their back on their
religion rabbis pastors um again it's
not just you know Jewish leadership it's
also Christian
leadership I think that it's important
for those that have
claim to be allies in the fight against
islamophobia to see that you cannot be
opposed to islamophobia while also
extending anti- Palestinian
bigotry yeah one of the things since we
last spoke I got to meet a lot of
Palestinian
Christians including in West Bank and
that was fascinating and those are
beautiful people I I think people should
watch Reverend unus Hawk uh sermon on
Christmas Jesus in The Rebel it was
deeply profound you know I I had a
chance to speak to Mitri Rahab uh from
the Lutheran Church there as
well no they're devastated you know I it
was eye opening to many people here when
when Justin Amish who was a republican
Congressman right Palestinian Christian
Republican Congressman posted about his
own family dying in one of the church
bombings uh so it's it's strange strange
times and I think that it shows that
the philosophy of hate that
drives this terrible policy uh is
secular at its root and not
religious